art Del Cueto National border patrol
Council vice president is in Focus now
first of all this is temporary more than
likely tell me what this accomplishes
any stay in title 42.
well I mean it's it's very minimum the
problem is like you said it is going to
be temporary the facilities are already
overrun
as soon as this Administration took over
the numbers jumped okay from the
previous administration being right
around a thousand a day the numbers
immediately Jumped close to over five
thousand right now the apprehensions are
over 8 000 per day so everything is
stretched in you have agents that have
been removed from the line they're
having to do cover positions and
processing and then the detention
facilities so the border is pretty much
wide open and there seems to be no
consequences for individuals entering
the United States right now all they got
to do is claim some type of Asylum and
they get released and as you said at the
top of the hour uh one of the big
problems of course is the gotaways you
know what we have right now is numbers
of what has been caught what has been
vetted and what obviously has been
released but God only knows how many
people have come through and uh you know
we don't know that number no one knows
that number it's just a guess and or
what their intentions would be to come
into the United States right now look
are you and I have known each other a
number of years you've done this job a
long time and and you know the numbers
uh that you just gave us are going to
increase when this goes away so that 8
000 that we popped to now we're looking
at 14 as many as 18 000 is what we're
hearing so with all of that knowledge
you say the borders basically open how
does it register with you when the White
House says if you tell people the
borders open you're helping the
Smugglers you're against the United
States
look right now that's saying that is is
ridiculous it's a slap in the face to
the men and women that are out there
putting their lives on the line and it's
a huge slap in the face to the American
public these these individuals are
coming into the country they're being
led by the cartels the cartels know
where to send them so they can bring
their product across they want to bring
drugs across and you know they continue
to bring drugs fentanyl heroin
methamphetamines and you know what those
drug dealers they don't care what side
of the aisle you're you're sitting on
they just want to bring drugs into the
United States and they just want to harm
American citizens at the same time when
they're Crossing individuals that don't
even pass the vetting system for Asylum
those are the individuals that have
serious criminal backgrounds they don't
care about the American public or what
side of the Iowa they're sitting on this
Administration needs to realize it's a
problem not just for their own political
agenda but it's a problem for every
single American in this country I want
to get to this because look some
municipalities and States we've already
seen them take this into their own hands
there's Democrat leadership down in El
Paso uh the Texas National Guard art
announcing the deployment of a
contingency Force to El Paso Texas let's
watch
we've been asked to expand our coverage
to include El Paso we've deployed more
than 400 soldiers from other locations
around Texas to uh to augment that Force
who will be out in force uh with a with
a force size that is intended to tell
them you cannot cross unlawfully look
Democrats have tried to make this a
republican issue a republican problem
but this is a Democrat mayor down in El
Paso Texas declaring a state of
emergency over the weekend to try to
deal with the surge of humanity awaiting
the end of title 42. this is reality no
matter what political stripe you wear I
go back to Art Del Cueto now to talk to
me about what it really takes 400
soldiers they're deploying to El Paso
you know and that's going to help as far
as deterring some of the traffic but
unfortunately you know the laws are very
specific and the policies under this
Administration are what they are those
individuals will just find other gaps
where they can come into the United
States and you know get processed and
end up getting released and that's the
problem it's going to take this
government the administration to
actually start taking care of the people
actually put aside their hatred for the
last Administration and realize that
they're doing more harm to Americans
right now that is a lot in one sentence
put aside their hate for the last
Administration and do the right thing
art let's get to the CNN's Don Lemon
getting into a very testy exchange with
former Republican Congressman will Hurd
who represented Texas border District
over the current state of the crisis
let's watch
I can make an argument that President
Biden's policies are more inhumane and
then Donald Trump's and Donald Trump's
was terrible you're going to be having
thousands of people sleeping on the
streets of El Paso and starting this
week is probably going to be below 20
degrees
um that's that's an inhumane policy
um and and they need to do more
Congressman give us a little time here I
understand you have a lot to say and
you've you know you said a lot of things
here so when we want to respond to some
of it
yeah how do you respond with letting
people suffer so you can keep your
politics in place uh former Congressman
heard went on to mention an alternative
way to expel illegal immigrants by using
something called title eight to deport
them some restrictions we put them up on
the screen for you just so we'll tick
through it include health-related
grounds so similar to title 42 but but
this predated it and they could do this
right now you could look at the criminal
record or criminal activity terrorist
activities failure to attend removal
proceedings misrepresentation of
documentation likelihood of becoming a
public charge let's go back to art art
those are all the things that you're
talking about and when I was at the
border just a few weeks ago back at the
end of September I mean the fake IDs and
things that were left in the brush along
the river that got them from wherever
they were coming from it wasn't going to
work in America so let's ditch them we
don't know who some of these people are
that's the problem we don't know who
they are and let's face it Harris you've
been down to the Border a lot more times
than some of the people in this
Administration
so I thank you I thank you for that one
uh but you're right look right now
people don't know who who these
individuals are that are crossing and
it's even a simpler form bring
immigration judges and Asylum officers
down to the border and detain these
people put the right facilities to
detain them don't release him there's no
consequences right now for committing
the crime and that's why people continue
to come into the United States illegally
uh one last with you if this goes away
uh in the short order if this is not
days but hours away are we ready to
protect the citizens of this country on
the border what do you need
you know definitely not right now it's
always knee-jerk reactions you remember
many times the Caravans that continued
to come across and even still the agency
was caught not knowing what to do at
those times right now under these
individuals that are coming across
unprecedented times the agency is not
prepared and we have not heard of any
plan that they're prepared and you know
obviously when you have people in the
white house that are denying that
there's a problem how prepared are you
going to be to take care of the problem
when it does happen thank you for doing
all that you can and leading those who
you lead art Del Cueto Down On the
Border thank you very much appreciate
your time
thank you hey it's Will Kane click here
to subscribe to the Fox News Channel on
YouTube it's the best way to get our
latest interviews and highlights and
click to subscribe to the will Kane
podcast for full episodes right now